hey you guys here we are once again with
flickers of fear and i promised that i
was going to be doing more giallo films
in the early part of this year just
because i felt like i've been neglecting
them a little bit so here's another one
that we're going to talk about now this
is a film
that was done by daario argento in 1987
and pretty not universally but pretty
widely considered uh maybe dario
argento's last great film or at least
you know his last really really decent
one before things started to get a
little
hit or miss let's call it that i would
probably agree with that although he did
do some good movies later on which i
will probably be talking about at some
point i actually really quite like the
stendhal syndrome which came out in 96 i
believe and he did one called sleepless
uh which i remember being pretty good
although i haven't seen it in a long
time so he did have some good ones in
there but he also had some not so good
ones in there
but i mean i think that most fans of
argento will agree that opera
while not
up there with you know suspiria deep red
tenebrae is definitely a really good
dario argento movie and really really
worth watching
now the interesting thing about this uh
it's called opera in the u.s i think in
other territories particularly in the uk
it's called terror at the opera but it's
the same movie
and this has kind of like an interesting
i guess uh history behind it now this
was the movie that he made after
phenomena uh which i talked about not
too long ago you know the one with
jennifer connelly uh talking to insects
and uh donald pleasance in the
wheelchair with the chimpanzee so there
was that whole thing
this one
seems like it almost
and i'm talking mostly about like kind
of the dakota like the last 10 minutes
of the movie i kind of feel like it
almost wanted to be in the same universe
in a weird way and i think initially
that uh dario wanted jennifer connelly
who had been in phenomena to be in this
one as well like as the in the main role
but then he decided that it would
probably be better to get somebody that
he hadn't worked with before uh so the
actress that's kind of the main uh thing
in this is actually named christina
marcilla marcelash i'm not sure how you
pronounce it she's a spanish actress and
uh from everything that i that i've
heard and it kind of makes sense with
like how the movie is but she was just a
very very difficult actress to work with
dario argento said that she was the most
difficult actress he had ever worked
with and coming from dario argento
that's really saying something
so the story behind this
was that a couple of years prior to this
movie being made
daario argento had been asked to
stage a uh kind of a more
i want to say like a more horror or a
creepier
kind of like stage version of the opera
now i've seen some people say that that
the opera was verdi's macbeth and i've
seen some sources say that it was
verdi's rigoletto but it was one or the
other so dario argento was asked to do
like to stage kind of a more macabre
like version of this opera and while he
was working on it it's ironically
everybody knew who dario argento was you
know what i mean so i'm assuming that
they brought him on to stage this
because they liked his
sensibility or like his visual style so
the fact that he came in and basically
tried to horror it up or try to like
goth it out or whatever uh the producers
were just like no we don't want to do
that now which like i said why did you
ask him in the first place whatever but
so that whole entire project fell
through
but because it did he kind of got
interested in the sort of
behind-the-scenes stuff like in that
goes into like staging an opera and he
wanted to do something with that so he
ended up writing this movie around it
which in a lot of ways and i think that
a lot i kind of feel like dario argento
i don't think that his movies are
necessarily all
autobiographical to some degree but he
usually does kind of insert a little bit
of himself or his own character
sometimes in different like he did it in
tenebrae uh where he was caught i you
know i don't think the the main
character in tenebrae was him because
you know he was a killer but
you know a lot of the stuff he's always
kind of like putting stuff from his own
life like into his movies and sort of
making sly you know winking references
to them and this is definitely one of
those cases because
the uh in this movie it kind of centers
around a sort of
avant-garde uh production of verdi's
macbeth
and the guy that's staging it in the
movie
is named marco
and he is explicitly called out in the
movie as being he was a horror director
and we asked him to do this and he had
done the rigoletto he had done rigoletto
prior and got really bad reviews for it
because they said that he was making it
too
crazy or you know whatever so dario
argento is definitely like putting
a little bit of himself or maybe a lot
of himself into this role and the
character of marco also gets accused of
being a sadist at one point like in the
movie and almost he's kind of like
threaded throughout the movie is they're
really trying hard to make you think
that uh you know that marco is the
killer so it's kind of like a red
herring type situation uh sadly the
character of marco who is the stage
manager like this producer of the whole
opera in the movie was p played by an
actor named uh ian charles charleston
charleston
who had been in i think he was in gandhi
and he was in uh cherries of fire and
stuff like that and uh i don't think
this was his last film role but
unfortunately um he was in a minor car
accident when he was on you know while
he was making this movie and while in
the course of getting medical treatment
uh
they discovered that he had aids
which he had suspected for some time and
he actually only lived a couple of years
after this i believe he died in 1990 so
that's kind of like a sad and it's
interesting too because it's almost kind
of like this movie
it's like you know anybody that works in
you know the theater or anything like
that or knows anything about that world
you know that macbeth has long been
considered like a bad luck
uh play so really anybody that puts it
on you're gonna have all this bad luck
like plaguing the production and that's
something that gets played upon a lot in
this movie as well
but interestingly when they were
shooting this movie there really did
seem to be a lot of like
bad luck [ __ ] going on too including
that car accident like a bunch of other
things as well uh you know it was just
kind of like it seemed like for dario
argento even though the movie came out
quite good and actually this is one i
mean visually i love this movie i think
the visuals of it are my favorite thing
and i really like all that kind of like
stuff that's set in the theaters that
like set around an opera so i really
really like the whole aesthetic of this
so this movie i think came out
pretty fantastic considering that dario
argento apparently really really did not
have a good time making this and had to
take a hiatus like after this movie was
done because he just had such a terrible
experience on it now another thing too
that is maybe like kind of comes from
real life like where he got the idea for
this
probably the most iconic image uh of
this movie and it was even used on the
poster and everything uh was of a woman
with her eyes really big and like uh
there are a bunch of like pins or
needles like taped underneath her eyes
so she can't close them
and dario argento said he had the idea
for this like before he made the movie
he's like because i was joking with a
friend of mine that i kind of like put
all of this work and stuff into making
these really like gory or fantastic like
set pieces in my movies only for people
to go see them and then like look away
so he was kind of joking i'd really like
to be able to like pin needles
underneath people's eyes so they had to
look at it so it's like a like clockwork
orange situation where he had his like
eyes like forced open so you'd have to
look at it so he kind of used that
uh that image or that joke that he made
uh in the course of this movie
so what we have as i mentioned uh the
movie revolves around a production of
verdi's macbeth
done by a dude named marco who is who
was previously a horror director
uh horror movie director and he's doing
kind of like uh create like an
avant-garde you know again like a more
macabre take on it only macbeth is a
pretty magob macabre play i mean to be
honest with you which is why it's my
favorite uh my favorite one but uh but
yeah so that whole situation is going on
now uh at the very beginning they have
uh the star who's playing lady macbeth
uh her name is mara kakova
and she's kind of like your typical you
don't really see her much because
she was initially supposed to be played
by vanessa redgrave
um and her part was larger but when
vanessa redgrave couldn't do it or left
the production or whatever uh dario
argento decided to cut the uh the role
way down so you barely see her in the
movie uh at the very beginning she's
kind of having a big like diva sort of
meltdown because of all the real ravens
that they're using you know in the
course of the production that are kind
of like whacking her while she's trying
to sing and everything like that and she
gets all
huffy about it and kind of storms out of
the theater
in a really great shot you actually
don't see her it's like a pov but it
almost looks like she's kind of like
walking backwards like out of thing
while she's like shouting at everybody
it's a great like i said visually like
the way the camera moves in this and
like just the way the shots are set up
and it's just the camera has this great
like fluid sort of
movement and it's just it looks
fantastic and it looks really good but
it's not
it's not necessarily like distracting
from the from the story i think it's
kind of like contributing to it or like
adding to it but it's just some of the
some of the ways the camera moves are
like really really beautiful which i'll
get into a bit later on because there
are some actually very very famous
sequences in this if you're into horror
movies particularly italian horror
so so yeah so our diva like storms out
the door and uh pretty much immediately
gets hit by a car she's not killed but
you know she's wounded bad enough that
obviously she can't do the performance
now
so then in comes her understudy there's
a much younger uh woman named betty now
uh betty's
agent or manager is played by daria
nickelode who you know most people know
she uh she and dario argento were a
couple for a very long time uh daria
nicolodi was also the co-writer on
suspiria and few of his other movies and
was in his movies a lot
now at this point in her career uh her
and daario had divorced or had split up
uh two years prior to this so she was
kind of reluctant to do it at first
but you know because you never know
what dario did maybe he's still mad you
don't know what he's gonna do to you on
the set of this movie and indeed
something really bad does happen around
the set of this movie but from
everything that i've heard uh she
actually wanted to do the movie because
of her death scene which is indeed quite
spectacular uh so maybe she didn't have
any hard feelings about that it's not a
huge part but
so she plays uh you know betty's manager
so she comes to betty's house and she's
like hey you have an hour to get ready
because you know the the main lady got
you know run over by a car and uh so
you're gonna play lady macbeth it's
gonna be you know this is your big break
and you know if you do really good and
we'll go to paris and roam and put
everywhere
so uh so betty is just kind of like
you'd think she'd be kind of jazzed
about it she's like well man man i'm
really too young to play lady macbeth
you know and plus macbeth as a play it's
like a bad it's bad luck and she's like
i don't necessarily want this to be my
big main debut and everything but
obviously you know they talk her into it
even though she's still pretty reluctant
so interestingly so she gets there she
puts on the
weird costume i think
i thought that for a minute because i'm
like looking at the at the production
design of this opera within the movie
and it's obviously trying to be like an
avant-garde and i think it was supposed
to be set
during
world war one i want to say well so you
couldn't really tell from her outfit
because i thought she looked a little
bit like
an 80s glam version of like a flapper
kind of but it was kind of hard to say
like what it was because the costume was
so strange but then there was like a
really quick shot of like a couple of
soldiers and i thought it looked like
world war one uniforms and that might be
because the uh the actual opera that
dario argento in real life
was going to do i think was was the
rigoletto or it might have been macbeth
and he was setting it at world war one
so i'm assuming that he just like
carried over his ideas
for the actual opera into the opera in
in the film's universe
so yeah so she has like this weird
outfit on it she goes out and she sings
and she's amazing and everybody is just
kind of like oh my god awesome awesome
but uh during the course of her you know
one of her uh you know solos or arias or
whatever
uh you see that there is somebody your
stereotypical giallo killer uh who has a
mask and a black glove and everything
who's up in the uh one of the boxes and
is watching her through binoculars and
is saying some really creepy [ __ ] um
you know like while he's looking at her
uh so you're led to assume it's this has
also like a phantom of the opera kind of
vibe which is interesting because dario
argento did a phantom of the opera
uh adaptation a few years after this i
don't remember when that came out it was
like early 90s because i think his
daughter asia was in it and i remember
it being okay i think it wasn't great
but yeah so but this definitely has
phantom of the opera kind of vibes to it
too because it's a killer who is
apparently obsessed with
this
young singer
and
it seems like what he's trying to do
is he doesn't necessarily want to kill
her
but he wants to make her watch him
kill other people
so what what he'll do
is he'll um you know she'll be someplace
like the first death actually like the
first death is
happens in the thing like during their
performance because like a light falls
down and everybody flips out and
everything but then it turns out that
somebody that worked in the theater that
came up and like told the guy hey you're
not supposed to be in here or whatever
and then he takes the guy and like
smashes the back of his head into like a
coat hanger thing like on the wall uh
which is pretty gruesome but then like
after the show
betty goes to her boyfriend's apartment
which i don't even want an apartment it
looks like a [ __ ] castle or something
and he says his uncle or his dad or
something is super wealthy and lets him
use the place or whatever and they're
like uh you know they they tried to have
sex but it didn't work out and
it's a long story and um so he goes to
get to make some tea
and while he's gone the killer comes in
takes her and puts uh tape over her
mouth ties her with rope like to this
pillar thing and puts the uh the pins or
needles under her eyes so that she has
to watch the killer killing her
boyfriend which uh he does in quite a
gruesome fashion he has like this really
big kind of
spade shaped knife and he just like
stabs the [ __ ] out of him so that kind
of um
how it goes on basically every you know
every few minutes or every 10 minutes or
whatever uh she'll be someplace and then
the killer will pop out and you know and
kill the person in front of her so the k
the killings in this are actually pretty
brutal and pretty gruesome uh as i said
her boyfriend getting stabbed is pretty
nasty there's actually what one of the
best shots which i think might have been
cut out of the uk version it's probably
been restored now but when he first
stabs the boyfriend he takes this big
ass knife and sticks it like right up
here like through his [ __ ] jaw and
then there's like a shot inside of his
mouth where you see like the blade
coming out it looks really good um but
yeah i think those couple seconds were
taken out of the uk but like i said it
might have been put back in there now
and then there's also another great
sequence where she's in this uh kind of
in the wardrobe department with the
wardrobe mistress whose name is julia
and she uh you know betty gets tied up
and has a pin on pin under pins under
her eyes and she's put like in this sort
of glass case or whatever so she can't
really do anything to help julia as
julia is getting killed now julia
actually does like fight back like the
killer like throws like a really heavy
iron at her which like hits her in her
lower back and knocks her over but then
she kind of like struggles and picks up
the iron and starts hitting the dude
with it and knocks him out for a second
but then instead of just like beating
the [ __ ] out of him until he's dead she
decides she's going to take his mask off
and see who he is so this is not that
long end of the movie so she takes the
mask off and she's like oh you know holy
[ __ ] it's him but you don't see who it
is um so then he comes back and like
strangles her now he had the reason that
he came in there was because he had lost
like a bracelet of his and it was kind
of caught in betty's costume that julia
was working on so he came in to get it
back so
julia knew that he wanted it so she was
just trying to keep it away from him
because she was just like [ __ ] you bud
you're not having it and uh so she but
she gets killed and it kind of falls in
her mouth and so there's again another
really great sequence where
you know the killer is kind of like
rooting around in her mouth like with
these big-ass scissors and he can't get
it so then he does you know kind of an
impromptu tracheotomy like to get it out
of there so like i said the killings in
this are pretty brutal now the best
killing that everybody talks about
anytime you see anything about italian
horror about adario argento movies even
about the best kills in horror movies
period
this scene is probably going to be in
there and like i said this is daria
nickelode's big moment this is like her
death scene there's this one scene later
in the film
where there's supposed to be a cop at
betty's apartment but there's some kind
of confusion over whether the cop is
downstairs or whether because the guy
comes up into her apartment and like she
thinks he's the cop so he's in there but
then uh daria nickelodeon's character
comes over and she's like no there was a
cop in the thing and he said what his
name was and it's funny because this cop
is played the his character's name is
daniele sawavi and he's actually played
by mikely sawavi who you know again
anybody that knows anything about
italian horror uh he directed a [ __ ] ton
of uh movies of his own including
cemetery man which is one of my favorite
ones and uh so he worked with dario
argento a lot and was in some of his
movies as well as well as directing a
bunch of his own
so uh so he's in this so there's some
confusion over well [ __ ] is the person
in the apartment the cop or the killer
or who's outside so we don't really know
so daria nickelodeon is like looking
through the peephole like out at this
dude being like are you really the cop
prove it like let me see you know your
id and she's like yeah that could be a
fake let me see your face so she's
holding her eye up to the people
and the dude basically just like sticks
his robot and shoots her through the
people so you have this great it's just
such a great sequence it's just it's
fantastic i love it so it's just kind of
like you see the bullet like going
through you know the tube like the
peephole and then it legit like goes in
and then pops out the back of her head
and then there's a great shot from like
a far shot from the end of the hall of
her just like falling backwards in slow
motion while the bullet kills the phone
like that's behind there like on this
with the phone just like blows up like
that it's a it's a fantastic [ __ ]
sequence and i should say too this movie
was made in 1987
uh so they didn't have cgi to do that
stuff so they basically had to put like
a little explosive charge on the back of
dary nickelodeon's head so she was a
little worried about it as you would be
uh but i have to say it looks great i
mean it definitely looks like it looks
real it really does look like a bullet
going through her head but yeah so they
definitely had to put like a [ __ ]
squib and all that kind of stuff on the
back of her head which
i see i don't think they would do that
nowadays but
but back in the 80s she kind of had to
do it and she was a trooper she like
went through it and like i said it's a
it's just the way it's shot it's just a
fantastic sequence
so as it goes on you know and and uh
betty is having to be witness to all of
these crimes that are taking place by
this kind of gloved and masked killer
and you know that he has some kind of
motive for wanting to keep her alive and
wanting her to be to watch and also kind
of threaded throughout the movie like
you know scattered throughout the movie
are these sequences which you're not
entirely sure i mean you're imagining
they're probably flashbacks where and
and i think that betty says at one point
too she's like you know i've dreamed of
this guy like you know from when i was a
kid i dreamed of like a guy with a mask
and you know and black gloves doing this
kind of stuff with a woman tied up and
you know watching someone else get
murdered
so you know that there's some kind of
like deeper thing going on there so it
turns out uh spoiler alert uh if you
haven't seen this uh and i will say too
that this is a giallo movie in the sense
of you know it being like a murder
mystery
but i will say that it's not a big
secret like who the killer is really i
mean you can you can guess like pretty
much from that as much as they try to
set up marco as the killer like the
stage production because sometimes like
he'll turn up at a place like right
after um
betty's boyfriend gets killed and then
betty runs out the [ __ ] apartment and
goes to um goes to a phone booth like to
call the police and report it and then
suddenly like marco just happens to be
driving past you know hey i was gonna go
do this thing and so it's c and he's
always kind of like around so it seems
like the movie's trying to set him up as
the killer because he always seems to be
conveniently around like when the when
the killings take place but
honestly like watching it because i've
seen opera several times but i hadn't
seen it for many many years so i
couldn't really remember like what
happened in it i couldn't remember who
the killer was but honestly pretty much
as soon as the killer turns up in the
movie um i'm like oh that's him and
indeed that's that's how there's not
really a lot of because you know in some
giallo movies there's like a [ __ ] ton of
like red herrings like there's like
seven different dudes it could be um you
know and and five different ladies it
could be this one there's not really a
lot of i mean marco is really the only
one that's kind of like a main enough
character
to
for you to think that maybe it's him but
the fact that they're trying to set it
up so much that means it's not him so
there's really only one left because
like i said she does have a boyfriend
but he gets killed like almost
immediately so you know it's not that
guy obviously um so it's there's not
like a big mystery uh the killer is uh
actually the cop inspector santini and
like i said pretty much the first time
you see him where he turns up uh you
know at her dressing room like after the
performance like to give her a flower
and i'm a fan and blah blah
you know that that's who it is and
indeed that's who it is now
interestingly santini
is played by urbano barbarini who was in
several other he was in demons too i
think and he was in like one other one
that i'm trying to think of but it's
funny because i recognized him from
outlaw of gore
which was on mystery science theater
that kind of terrible like
sword and sorcery movie that also had
jack palance in it like in a silly hat
uh but yeah so i recognized rapano
barbarini from that awful movie it's an
awful movie but it's uh the mystery
science theater episode of it is like
one of my favorite ones just because
there's so much [ __ ] to make fun of but
it's just funny i had forgotten that he
was in this so like when i'm looking at
him i'm like oh my god it's [ __ ]
it's cabot cabot cabot it's cabot but
yeah so i thought that was really funny
he was in a bunch of italian movies so
i'm just i'm not [ __ ] on him just
for that one but you know so yeah so it
turns out that santini's the killer and
the reason that he's doing it is because
when he was a teenager he apparently had
this really weird [ __ ] up sexual
relationship with betty's mom who was
also an opera singer
betty's mom apparently got off on being
tied up
and watching
santini killing people but then what
happened was that betty's mom got a
little too
uh demanding he says so he ended up
having to kill her
and uh so then but now like now that
betty's around
uh he's like i'm you know he wants to
carry on the tradition i guess so i
think that he thinks that that betty has
the same perversions as her mom so he's
kind of like trying to awaken that in
her i guess by tying her up and making
him watch her watch him kill people
so so that's kind of like where this
like and then that's why like that's
where the flashbacks come in because the
flashbacks were
betty is a little girl
seeing her mom tied up and seeing this
guy there like stabbing people in front
of the bomb and that's what she's
remembering even though most of it is
repressed the way they catch him is
actually quite cool remember at the very
beginning i said that there was a whole
bunch of ravens uh that were part of the
production and that the original uh lady
the original woman that was playing lady
macbeth uh she was like pissed off about
so what ends up happening is that when
the killer before you know who it is
goes back stage to [ __ ] with betty's
costume
all the ravens get out
and they sort of like attack him like
what the [ __ ] are you doing in here
buddy and uh so he kills like two or
three of the ravens
now there's kind of a line later on like
from the guy that's like the raven
trainer
and he's saying oh you know ravens are
really really smart and if you [ __ ] with
them like they hold grudges and they
will remember for a really long time
which is absolutely true you know maybe
not to the extent that you see in this
movie but it is based in reality it's
not a crazy idea it is actually true
they do recognize people and they do
hold grudges for at least a month um
maybe longer
so uh so how they decide how marco
decides to catch the killer before again
before they find out know who it is is
that they said well we assume that this
killer is obsessed with you so we assume
that he will be at tonight's performance
so what he decides to do is in the
middle of the performance he's gonna let
all the ravens loose in the theater and
uh let the ravens
remember the person like and find him
and they'll be able to know who he is
and this actually works like gangbusters
again this is another very famous uh
scene from this movie because it almost
goes into like
uh ravencam where
it's just this great like swirling shot
like around the audience and this you
know beautiful [ __ ] uh opera house
they used obviously it's a real opera
house it's in parma i believe
and uh so they used this big it's kind
of like uh because i think remember when
i was talking about uh tenebree where
they have that really long like that
luma camera shot that just goes up the
building and like it through past all
the windows and stuff this is kind of
like that but it's sort of like the next
generation of that where it's just kind
of like this swirling
uh sort of thing and i read somewhere
that
daario argento before he made this movie
he was really excited to work with the
this new version of the luma that kind
of did all the spirally like fluid kind
of movements
so he actually took a job on a car
commercial that was using that just so
he could like learn how to use it like
for his movies and stuff so
so again it's like a really great it's
it's following the the movements of the
ravens as they fly all around the thing
and like i said it's just this beautiful
like fluid spiral kind of thing and like
everyone's kind of like ducking out of
the way of the ravens and stuff like
that it's really cool so the ravens all
obviously land on santini and uh pluck
his eye out and eat it so that's nice uh
but after he gets caught like he runs
away and then he ends up uh you know
kind of finding betty and trapping her
in this room expositing like all like
you know what was going on with the mom
and all this other stuff like his
motives but then he's basically like
we're gonna die together now
so she he has her tied up with a you
know with a thing over her eyes so she
can't see then he's like well i'm gonna
burn this room down but i want you to
shoot me first but obviously she can't
see so she can't really do it all that
well so uh but it does work out she kind
of shoots him or so she thinks and then
the room catches on fire but she can't
get out and uh so there's all this you
know
confusion about it but finally they get
her out and the dude looks like he's
burned to death and it looks like a
happy ending now interestingly
okay so what happened after that but
okay what they wanted
this was released uh you know in europe
in theaters it was supposed to be
released in the u.s in theaters as well
but the american distributors said we
don't like the last 10 minutes the coda
of the movie can you please take that
out so it would have ended right where
the killer was supposedly burned to
death the end
daario said no i'm not going to do that
because i like the ending
so they were like well then we're not
gonna distribute it to the theaters then
so it basically just went right to vhs
now uh again the last 10 11 minutes of
this are kind of controversial because
after the whole fire and everything like
that so then you see betty and marco
and they've gone off to marco's house
which is in the swiss alps so again
you're getting a real phenomenal vibe
here too because i believe that was also
filmed in the swiss alps
so they're kind of hanging out in the
house or whatever and then it comes over
the news that yeah we thought that
santini guy was dead like in the fire
but then it turned out that that wasn't
even a body that was a mannequin so he
had staged his whole thing he faked his
death essentially
so uh so by the time that they see that
on the news santini obviously has
already found her in the swiss alps so
now they're like chasing around and
everything like that
so uh marco ends up getting stabbed
and uh betty
to
kind of get uh i think she knows the
cops are coming because she sees like a
helicopter flying over
so she basically says over the body of
marco she says yeah that's what i wanted
to happen i'm just like my mom we're
gonna have this whole situation we're
gonna have this whole relationship now
just like you had with my mom you woke
up woke it up in me and blah blah and he
falls for it um so because i think at
first like maybe some people were
hearing that being like wait what maybe
because that was one way that they were
gonna let the script go that she was
actually like yeah i'm into this like
let's let you kill people and i'll watch
i get off on it now so i think some
people did think that maybe they're like
wait what that she actually is gonna
like team up with this dude now but no
it was just a ruse like to kind of uh
throw him off guard she ends up beating
the [ __ ] out of him like uh you know
with a rock or whatever and then the
cops come and take him away and then
there's a very weird sequence where
betty i don't know i guess it's meant to
imply that she's just kind of like gone
off the deep end because of all this
trauma which you know like i said is
understandable because she just
basically starts crawling on the ground
and being like
i'm just like she doesn't want to hang
around with humans anymore she just
wants to hang out with the wind and the
trees and the insects and stuff and then
there's just kind of like there's this
little lizard and he's like stuck under
a branch and he's like looking at her
like help me help me and she's like
there you go little buddy you know what
i mean she's like you're free and now
i'm free and she's all like that so it's
just like a really weird like i said so
it's almost kind of like he wanted to
tie this in with
phenomena
in the sense that
you know now she's kind of like
gone to nature because of her i don't
know if it was meant to imply that she
had lost her mind completely or not uh
but that was the impression i got but
maybe not maybe i'm like reading too
much into it but you know i don't know
but as i said uh this is generally
considered dario argento's last great
film
uh from 1987 and it's one that a lot of
people don't really talk about all that
much which is kind of sad honestly i
really really like this movie i had seen
it several times but i hadn't seen it uh
for many years at this point and i
actually watched it on 2b it's on 2b for
free if you want to watch it actually a
bunch of his movies are on there for
free interestingly and i had forgotten
how visually
stunning this was it's not as stylized
as something like you know inferno or
suspiria with these bright colors it
does have a little bit of that but i
think the main visual thing that i love
about this one is the camera movements
and the framing i just think like i said
that whole scene where daria nickelodeon
gets shot through the eyeball like
through the peephole and then like that
long shot of her like falling backward
in slow motion it's just gorgeous it's a
gorgeous
shot and it's just there's so much
beautiful you know and even like some of
like the trick shots you know or the
or you know if you want to go like
pretentious film routers live you know
raven cam with like these swirling
camera movements as i said it doesn't
seem
it doesn't seem affected to me it seems
like it's all kind of of a piece with
the whole theme of the movie uh being
very operatic being you know having all
of this opera music in it and being kind
of over the top in that way
so it doesn't really bother me it
doesn't really stick out it really seems
like it all
works together really nicely uh just
these kind of great tracking shots and
they're just so fluid and it's just i
just love the just the whole movement of
the movie i think is like really really
cool uh again i really like movies set
around the theater around operas um and
you know this one
just it's gorgeous like all of the
staging and all the you know it's just
curt red curtains and these great big
sets and like the beautiful opera house
that they filmed and it's just a
gorgeous gorgeous movie the production
design and everything like that really
beautiful as i said it's not as
hyper real or you know super colorful
like some of his earlier films uh it is
quite grounded in reality it doesn't
really have any supernatural elements to
it unless you want to call the raven
things supernatural which it's not
really because like i said ravens do
actually hold grudges against people
they've done studies of that
so that's not all that supernatural but
honestly i really i like this one a lot
better than phenomena i just like the
whole vibe of it i like phenomena too
but phenomena is a little
weird
where it's just kind of like weird
supernatural stuff with like kind of all
these zany elements in it this one is
much more like a traditional jollo but
with all of those stylish elements that
you love so much from dario argento will
say i'm not a huge fan of the score i
like all the opera and some parts of the
score are good i think it looks like
brian eno did some of it and i think
bill wyman worked on it but then there's
a lot of which i don't really consider
this part of the score but like during
some of the kills it's kind of like
heavy metal or like hard rock which i
know he does a lot because he worked
with uh you know some other bands like
that particularly around like demons and
stuff like that which kind of had a like
a lot of punk and metal in it it works
in this one i think better than some of
the other movies that he put it in but i
still don't love it i kind of wish that
he would have gone full-on
opera or a more like regular score
than kind of doing these
hard rock sequences like when the kills
were taking place but that's just me
because i know some i've seen some other
reviews of it and people really dug that
and thought it worked really well
together and i guess it does it works
better than some of the other films that
he's done that in but
i kind of wish that everything had been
more like operatic i think that would
have been a lot better but like i said
there is a lot of opera in this which i
dug so i thought that was pretty cool
but yeah if you haven't seen this one
and if you've liked some of dario
argento's other stuff particularly his
other giallo movies
this one's not
you know it's not his best one but it's
still a pretty damn good one and i feel
like a lot of people don't really talk
about it so uh you know if you've seen
it let me know what your opinion of it
is
if you haven't seen it you can watch it
for free on to be at least as of this
recording so go and watch it and let me
know what you think about it in the
comments and that will do it for this
flickers of fear i will see you guys on
the next one bye